Speaker 1: Let's talk about a new movement within
the Republican Party. And the question at the end
that I want to come back to is, is this a net good
or a net bad for the United States of America? So
Madison Cawthorn, radical, Trumpist Republican
Congressman Madison Cawthorn, after just six
months in office, is already on his way out. He
will be leaving in January. He lost his primary
to a challenger in North Carolina on Tuesday. And
at least part of the reason that Madison Cawthorn
lost is that he became the focus or the target
of what we might call establishment Republicans.
Madison Cawthorn has had a bunch of run ins with
the law, a couple of very high speed speeding and
potentially reckless driving incidents involving
his vehicle three times caught bringing a firearm,
trying to bring firearms through TSA security and
bringing a gun to a school I'm sorry, a knife to
a school council meeting of some kind, and then
saying that he gets invited to cocaine fueled
orgies by other members of Congress. And it became
very clear that the Republican Party establishment
decided, we're going after this guy and they
succeeded. The group that released some of the
controversial videos of Madison Cawthorn
say that they are going to be targeting
radical Trumpist lunatic. Congresswoman Lauren
Boebert next. Business Insider reporting Madison
Cawthorn foes who targeted him with a damaging
nude, nude video say Lauren Boebert is next on
their hit list, the group that posted a viral
sexually explicit video of a nude congressman,
Madison Cawthorn, with another man in bed is now
focusing on Colorado Representative Lauren Boebert
for its next takedown, insider has learned.
David Wheeler, who's the co-founder of the
American Muckrakers PAC, said to insider, quote,
I think we're going to go after Lauren Boebert and
Colorado in a similar way. I think we're going
to engage in that race pretty quickly. Wheeler
is a Democrat. His co-founder is unaffiliated. The
group has Republicans among its advisers. Wheeler
said he's received interesting information about
the Republican firebrand Boebert, whose primary
against Republican State Senator Don Corum is
on June 28. The information is, quote, certainly
not as salacious as some of the Cawthorn stuff.
It deals instead with financial matters, and he
didn't yet disclose more of it. A spokesperson
for Boebert did not immediately respond to a
request for comment. Now is the article points
out. Previously, Lauren Boebert has also had
issues when it comes to campaign finance. Last
year, the AP reported that Boebert failed to
disclose her husband's income during the campaign
in violation of ethics and campaign finance laws.
She revealed her husband made nearly $1,000,000 in
2019 and 2020 as a consultant for an energy firm.
So what's the what's the question that we have to
ask here? Is this good or bad for the country? And
what do I mean by that? Well, it's abundantly
clear that there are far less crazy Republicans
out there and that as a general thing, replacing
a crazy Republican with a less crazy Republican
is good, in a sense. But at the same time, if
the less crazy Republicans can get things done
versus these wild Trumpists who say a lot of wacky
things but don't get anything done and sometimes
even get kicked off of committees, is the country
better off with the crazier Republicans in
office? I mean, Marjorie Taylor GREENE is a good
example. Marjorie Taylor GREENE was stripped of
her committee assignments and essentially has no
influence in the House of Representatives. I think
you can find some areas around the fringes
where maybe she is influencing someone but very,
very little. Matt Gaetz has some influence, but
also he's kind of a laughingstock. If you replace
those people with, you know, hardworking, kind
of buttoned up Republicans, if if you replace
them with people like Mitt Romney, who would
would certainly get fewer headlines but might
be more effective at getting legislation passed
or whipping votes or whatever the case may be. Is
the country better off or not? Obviously, when you
take a very wide view and you say, well, listen,
if you take eight outrageous, lunatic Republicans
and replace them with people with whom, you know,
we kind of like we disagree on taxes and
abortion, but they're not out of their minds.
It sounds like that's an improvement. But at the
same time, if they can actually accomplish things,
maybe it's better to have the wackier
people in office. I want to hear from you.
And, you know, this is also a conversation which
we may be having in the context of 2024, because
we talk about DeSantis versus Trump if they both
were to run for the Republican nomination in 24.
DeSantis is almost as crazy as Trump. But
he's far more competent. And so in reality,
are we better off with Trump, even though
he's more of a global laughing stock?
I don't know. This is a prediction. It's an it's
a guess. It's an estimate. It's not something we
can say for sure in advance. But I want to hear
from you about it. Let me know your thoughts.